من جانبه قال عضو المكتب السياسي لجماعه
انصار الله الحوثييين ان قصف التحالف
الامريكي البريطاني لمحافظات يمنيه لن
يغير موقف الجماعه ولن يوقف عملياتها
العسكريه التي تقوم بها ضد اسرائيل حتى
تتوقف الاباده الجماعيه في قطاع غزه ويرفع
الحصار عن سكان القطاع واضاف البخيتي في
منشور على موقع اكس ان العدوان الامريكي
البريطاني على اليمن لن ي يمر دون رد وان
الجماعه قا تقابل التصعيد بالتصعيد على حد
تعبيره انضم الينا من واشنطن مراسل
الجزيره محمد الالمي محمد منذ البدايه كان
هناك موقف معلن بان هذه الضربات يجب ان
تكون جراحيه ومحدوده بحيث لا يتوسع نطاق
الحرب
والتصعيد هل هذا ما بات حتى الان الان
ملتزما به وفق نطاق هذه
الضربات لا يبدو الامر كذلك
مياده خاصه بعد
24 ساعه من الهجوم الانتقامي لمقتل ثلاثه
جنود امريكيين على مواقع في سوريا
والعراق واضح
ان جهود القياده المركزيه انتقلت الى
اليمن في هجمات متتاليه وما اشرت اليه قبل
قليل كان هو الهجوم الاكبر الذي توسط
هجومين اصغر
حجما
الاول بعد ظهر السبت بالتوقيت المحلي
واستهدف هجوما على مجموعه من صواريخ كروز
سته صواريخ كروز كما قالت القياده
المركزيه
الامريكيه والتي كانت
في اراض ومواقع تابعه لانصار الله
الحوثيين في اليمن وكانت تشكل من وجهه نظر
القياده المركزيه خطرا عاجلا على الملاحه
التجاريه وعلى القطع البحريه الامريكيه
وتم التصدي لها بعد ذلك جاءت العمليه
الكبرى
التي ساهمت فيها الولايات المتحده
وبريطانيا وسته من حلفائها ويبدو انها
قامت بعمليه واسعه النطاق استهدف
36 هدفا مختلفا في اكثر من من ع مواقع
مختلفه يبدو انها كانت ضربه استباقيه
استهدفت ذخيره مخزنه تحت الارض انظمه
صواريخ وانظمه رادارات على الرغم من ان كل
هذه الاهداف لم تشكل اي خطر عاجل او ان
على القوات الامريكيه في البحر الاحمر او
على الملاحه التجاريه وكان الغرض منها حسب
بيان القياده المركزيه هو النيل من قدرات
الحوثيين على شن اي هجمات في المستقبل
احدث بيان للقياده
المركزيه جاء قبل ساعات قليله جدا حينما
اعلن انه في الرابعه
صباحا بتوقيت صن
شنت القوات الامريكيه قوات التابعه
للقياده المركزيه هجوما بالطائرات وب
صواريخ كروز المنطلقه من القطع البحريه
الامريكيه ضد صاروخ كروز او عفوا الصوارخ
الامريكيه كانت صوارخ توماهوك لكن هاجمت
صاروخ كروز كان يستعد للاطلاق من الاراضي
التي يسيطر عليها الحوثيون في خطوه دفاع
عن النفس كما ذبت القياده المركزيه على
وصف مثل هذه العمليات التي لا يبدو انها
اتت اكلها حتى الان ميدانيا لانها لم تثني
الحوثيين على عدم اطلاق اي صواريخ او
مسيرات كما انها تاتي في اطار كما اشرت
مياده في
اطار الاصرار الامريكي سواء من العسكريين
او من السياسيين على ان الولايات المتحده
مصممه على عدم توسيع هذا راع وانها لا
تريد لهذه الحرب ان تتسع وانها لا تريد
حربا في منطقه الشرق الشرق الاوسط لكن
يبدو للمراقبين انه يوما بعد يوم يبدو ان
الولايات المتحده تنجر تدريجيا لمواجهه في
منطقه الشرق الاوسط